60.
THES
>> HE STRIPPED THE PUCK FROM
JOSEPH..
HEDM LOOKING.
SCORE!
MARK STONE ON THE
VASILEVSKIY.
THERE'S NO KICKING.
HE MAY HAVERE'S REILLY SMITH.
MARCHESSAULT WILL TRACK ON THAT
FIRST POWER PLAY.
ANOTHER ONE COMING IN TRYING TO
E
NET AND AN OFF A
MARK STONE SECOND OF COLTON GOT
THROUGH AND BY THE PUCK. '18,
VEGAS, SCORE!
WHAT A MOVEIRS ON VASILEVSKIY.
WHAT GOAL.
THAT TIES CAREER HIGH IN GOA NE.
THE LIGHTNING.
SCORES!
NICE PASS. NET.
HE THREADS THAT BETWEEN THE
SKATES OF ROY.
YOU CAN SEE ALL FIVE SCORES!
THE LIGHTNING WITH TWO QUI
IT GOES OFF CIRELLI AND OFF
THEODORE ON TOP.
WATCH THE LINE OF HIS LEFT.
KARL SECONDS LEFT NOW.
>> BEST CHANCE COMING IN IT GAMH
ANLOCKED.
STEVENSON AND PUCK SCORES SHORTN
ALL 20 OF THEIR WINS.
THEY ARE CLOSE IN FRONT GOOD JO.
THEODORE
BROKEN UP.
AND NOW THEY'RE BACK HAS
THE SHOT AND EVERYBODY LOOKS FOR